[Music]
this week on brian ross investigates
the president and the playboy playmate
karen mcdougall says
she has asked god's forgiveness and
repented for what she says was her
10-month affair with a married man
absolutely i had to i
i knew it was wrong it was a spinning
god eyes in god's eyes
um yeah i repented she was paid 150 000
to keep quiet about an affair the white
house says never happened
and now she's answering our questions do
you imagine donald trump has in any way
repented
to be honest i doubt it plus the trump
tax returns
the new york times says it has them it's
totally fake news
made up fake is he really a billionaire
can he pay off his debts how does he
manage to pay
only 750 a year in taxes
pulitzer prize-winning journalist and
author david k johnston joins us
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree
with what the editors of mediaite have
to say about the bombshell reporting
from the new york times
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigators
good thank you for joining us and
welcome to our viewers on facebook live
and youtube live i'm brian ross joined
tonight as always by my colleague rhonda
schwartz and rhonda
the fascinating story as you know
ago that we thought what we had was a
bombshell interview
with former playboy playmate karen
mcdougall who was going to lay out all
the details of what she said was a
steamy
ten-month affair with donald trump
that's right brian and then suddenly she
canceled the interview
it was only later we learned that the
national enquirer
and a deal worked out by then president
trump's personal attorney
had promised her 150 000 and to promote
her
career as a fitness model if she didn't
talk about the affair
it's a practice that's become known as
catch
and kill
and of course what we wanted to do was
catch and broadcast
and now four years later after we came
up with some new information
karen mcdougall has finally agreed to
answer our questions on the record
along with her lawyer carol heller
telling us she now has asked for god's
forgiveness
for her sins you know god forgives i've
repented for what i've done
what i did back then with mcdonald i've
apologized publicly
and most importantly i've been forgiven
by jesus so i'm happy
i'm at peace i love where i'm at today
and honestly i love who i am today
and you feel you had to repent for what
happened with donald trump
absolutely i had to i i knew it was
wrong it was a sinning god eyes
in god's eyes um yeah i repented and
you know i'm not going to keep
apologizing for it because i've already
apologized i've already repented and you
know i'm
unforgiven and in my father's eyes so
the world can look at me how they look
at me and that's okay
i understand um but i've moved on and
i'm
at peace do you imagine donald trump has
in any way repented
um i can't say what what he has and
hasn't done with
his wife and his family but
i doubt it when her story did come out
it was big news
they met she says in june 2006 at this
party at the playboy mansion during the
filming of the apprentice
wow beautiful throughout the night it
was kind of obvious that there was an
attraction
from his part to me only later would the
story of the 150 000
payment come out and as you recall prior
to the
signing the deal you were talking with
me and what rhonda schwartz about doing
an interview when we worked at abc news
then and then that got cancelled
the deal was canceled because we had
signed the deal with ami
um in order for me to work and never
talk about it again
we never talk about the relationship and
where we kind of
so we were sort of leveraged for you in
a way
i didn't know that at the time but i
assumed that you probably were yes
and i i really want to reiterate that
karen was more
than willing to talk to you and did in
great detail
knowing with no expectations of having
any kind of compensation
and i think people should be aware of
that that you are not
ever giving a promise to pay anything it
was going to be completely gratis
the white house has denied that trump
had a sexual relationship with karen
mcdougall
but she says she kept a calendar or
diary of the 10 months she was with
trump
making note of each time they had sex
including
one episode she says at trump's new york
city apartment
when his wife melania was out of town
and were you in love with him
i was back then am i now which everyone
has accused me of based on the last and
the one and only interview i've done
no i'm not in love with him today was i
back then for my own personal reasons
yes i thought that i was and what do you
make of him today
no comments um
you know i um you know brian that was 14
years ago that i knew
donald aka president trump as we know
him today
um i don't think that he's the same
person that i knew
i think back then he seemed much sweeter
nicer more concerned about people's
feelings
you know the man i personally knew was
not this man that i see on tv
now do i disagree or and or agree with
his policies there are some i like and
some i disapprove of
greatly and she says she later heard
from people
at the national enquirer that trump when
he was president
wanted to know if she was still
interested in him
i was asked it's all hearsay of course i
was asked
if um i still cared or
loved donald and i said why do you ask
that and he said well donald was asking
somebody does she still love me i just
laughed it off
i don't know yeah no no i don't love him
but no i just laughed off the situation
so karen looking back on looking back on
this
four year saga do you wish perhaps you
had done the interview with us and
called it done
i do actually um it was a whole
big ordeal i just wish i would have come
clean in the beginning
let it out and kind of relax after that
because it was
it was a kind of a nightmare for a while
in in every sense of the word and
from a to z it was a flat-out nightmare
brian it was very scary i actually went
into hiding for a while
um even in heidi and i had strange
people follow me around
knocking at my door different times of
the day scared to death following me
home from
events church whatever it was pretty
scary and
it's nothing i really want to do again
if you have to tell the truth you must
tell the truth so at the same time
it's kind of a knowing situation you
tell the truth no good deed goes
unpunished but yet
i don't know brian it's just a weird
situation i got myself into and it was
just the two of us
as you know we weren't really backed by
anyone it was just
the two of us alone and i think we did
pretty well together
karen are you supporting a candidate in
particular this
year in the presidential election
uh brian i think i'm going to support
the candidate that i feel best unifies
us as a country
and i'll leave it at that all right well
uh carol heller and karen mcdougall
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight
thank you
and ronda one update last week a federal
judge threw out a definition lawsuit
that karen had brought
against tucker carlson and fox news
ronda
that's right and the judge said that
tucker carlson's comments were just
rhetorical hyperbole and opinionated
commentary
karen and carol called this a victory
saying it just shows it was fake news
propaganda
all right coming up next trump's taxes
the new york times says they have them
we'll talk with pulitzer prize-winning
journalist david k johnston
who's been tracking trump's finances for
years
when we come back you're watching the
long crime trial network
and quite a surprise this morning as we
woke up a september surprise from the
new york times saying
it had almost two decades worth of
donald trump's taxes
the tax returns congress and prosecutors
have been trying to get a hold of
to join us to talk about that is david k
johnston a
journalist and author of two great books
about donald trump the making of donald
trump and another one
it's even worse than you think and david
k johnson a lot in this uh
reporting by the times to unpack huge
debts that may come
due very soon gigantic losses
and in his first two years as president
he paid only 750
here's my first question for you why
seven hundred and fifty dollars instead
of zero
do you think i was just he could say i
pay some taxes
uh it's a plug number in a draft tax
return that got into the one they sent
in
uh donald is notorious for telling
uh his tax advisors and others in
previous cases
uh the number of tax the tax number is
too high it was too big
find a way to bring it down and line 56
the tax return they just plugged in 750
dollars and it stuck at the end of the
day
has nothing to do with what he should
have paid right so he could honestly say
i did pay taxes
that year what for you what's the most
important aspect of this what's the
biggest
takeaway well this report makes it very
clear that donald trump is in fact as
i've said for a long time
a major league calculated serial tax
cheat
uh it shows quite clearly that he has
taken
uh personal deductions some of them
relatively minor but
personal deductions that don't belong uh
it has
huge holes in it you know just bulk
amounts for things like legal services
uh that i'm sure will not stand up to
scrutiny
to audit a tax return you have to have
the business records and the accounting
records behind the tax return
secondly the size of the losses in 2008
and 2009
donald took 1.4
billion dollars of tax deductions
he doesn't have assets big enough to
justify that
kind of a number and a lot of people are
saying oh well he's in real estate
people in real estate don't have to pay
taxes
that's true if you're really big in real
estate you know what you're doing you
can live tax free
but donald got rid of most of his real
estate most of his income is from
licensing deals
and his television show so that doesn't
wash
david anymore question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
so david could he be prosecuted
for this what would be required to take
this
or prosecutor to do something with this
information what do you think
well he can't be prosecuted federally so
long as he is president
under the policies of the justice
department however
that would change the moment he leaves
office unless he were to resign
uh and the first way mike pence to
pardon him
uh and it would all clear such a pardon
would hold up
a supreme court might well declare that
to be a sham but the state of new york
is already pursuing him and all they
need to finish their case to bring an
indictment
are the records of the mazers accounting
firm
they have the tax information they've
had it for a long time they apparently
have the deutsche bank information
according to david enrich at the new
york times
and they've had some cooperation from
alan weiselberg
who is the chief financial officer of
the trump organization
so it's the accounting records they need
and donald's just trying to delay that
eventually
the prosecutors in new york city will
get the
records and i expect we'll see an
indictment very quickly after that
for not just tax fraud but apparently
insurance fraud falsifying business
records
and it's important ronda to keep in mind
that when donald had his two
income tax fraud trials
uh they were criminal but it was
established at one trial
that he's a he's a forger he forged the
tax return a signature on the tax return
so i'm sure there's other stuff that
will be found as well
and david here's what president trump
had to say from the white house about
the new york times story
it's totally fake news made up fake
we went through the same stories you
could have asked me the same questions
four years ago i had to litigate this
and talk about it
uh totally fake news no actually i paid
tax but and you'll see that as soon as
my tax returns
it's under audit they've been under
order for a long time
the irs does not treat me well they
treat me like the tea party like they
treated the tea party
and they don't treat me well they treat
me very badly
you have people in the irs they're very
they treat me very very badly
uh but they're under audit and
when they're not i would be proud to
show but that's just fake news
the new york times tried it the same
thing they want to create a little bit
of a story a little bit
they're doing anything and now the
president is saying the new york times
acted illegally in getting a hold of his
tax returns what do you make of that
argument and what do you think is the
source of all this
information
well first of all the times didn't do
anything illegal nor did i when i got
donald's 2005 tax return but this was
totally predictable in fact
the first thing i thought is donald's
going to claim and maybe even have bill
barr announce an investigation
in donald's claim that it's fake news
there's so much detail in the story you
couldn't fake it if you tried the best
novelists in the world couldn't put
together all the detail that's involved
here
now when trump says he's paid millions
of dollars in taxes
well sure he has employees he pays
social security taxes and payroll other
payroll taxes on their behalf
he has property taxes he pays when you
can make that case that's not the issue
the issue is his personal federal income
tax
and with so many uh loans coming due in
the next two or three years hundreds of
millions of dollars
is he facing bankruptcy do you think
donald sold
all of his stocks or virtually all of
them uh he sold
the incredibly valuable apartments in
new york city that he inherited from his
father
20 years ago and he needs
cash to pay bills there's no indication
that he's got
300 million dollars to pay the
personally guaranteed loans are coming
on the other hand brian
can you imagine a bank in the united
states even deutsche bank
regulated by the trump administration
saying to the president we're going to
foreclose on your doral country club
because
you haven't paid the money you owe us
and if in fact as there's very good
reason to believe
his deutsche bank loans are backed on
the other side by deposits
from russian criminals guaranteeing the
payment of those
loans then we have a really serious
national security threat
to worry about here and absolutely
the deutsche bank loans were really
disguised loans from russian criminals
david k johnson thank you so much for
joining us coming up next this week's
winners and losers in the media
time now for our winners and losers this
week in the media
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin the
editor chief of mediaite
which like the law on crime trial
network is part of the dan abrams
media empire and eden let's start with
the winner this week
dean mckay the editor of the new york
times
that's right so the new york times as
i'm sure all of your viewers know
just dropped a massive story about
president donald trump's taxes
um it's a really impressive feat of
reporting you know this has been a huge
story for the past couple years
the president has refused to release his
tax returns unlike
presidents that have come before him and
the times got access to
all of his tax return data and they are
not releasing
the tax returns or publishing them in
full to protect their sources
but they dropped an incredibly extensive
report on what was revealed in those tax
returns
uh the headlines include that uh
president donald trump only paid 750
in federal income tax in 2016 and 2017.
now a huge amount of credit obviously
goes to the reporters
who have been working around the clock
uh to basically sum up this story
uh and but i think we also you know need
to give some credit to dean mckay who's
the executive editor
of uh the new york times and oversaw all
of this reporting
he wrote an editor's note for the
website in which he explained
why they released it the story as they
did
and it really gives some fascinating
insight into how the new york times
worked to get this out and did you think
the editor's note was somewhat defensive
sort of getting ahead of potential
criticism from the white house
you know there was a note at the end
where he said that uh
you know there may be questions about
whether or not we should be reporting on
uh tax returns uh but he said that you
know the job of journalism is to
release information and this is
eminently uh
newsworthy information i didn't think he
needed to defend the reporting
to that extent i don't think anyone
except the white house which has
dismissed this story as fake news
is questioning whether or not it's
newsworthy uh to to report on uh the
president's finances
uh so yeah i'm not sure he needed to get
defensive about that at the end
but it was an interesting insight into
how the new york times is thinking about
this
and it is so revealing that the fight
over the president's tax returns is
going on in the courts now for more than
a year
suddenly they show up in the front page
of the new york times
exactly yeah i mean i expected this
information to come out
through the house of representatives or
any number of bodies that are doing
investigations into the president's
finances
uh the fact that it's the new york times
that reported this and reported in such
an extensive way
uh is really evidence of its power and
it's uh
how impressive it is as a reporting body
with much more to come and this week's
losers fox and friends talking about
these
very stories what do you make of the
timing of this the tax thing coming out
you know a day before
the debate and how is he preparing for
the debate yeah we've seen this play out
before
where there was a hit piece about the
president's taxes
uh just before a debate and an accurate
one
at that yeah so fox and friends actually
had a really good booking this morning
uh this new york times story came out on
sunday evening
and uh the president president trump
addressed it in a press briefing
now on fox and friends on monday morning
uh kaylee mcinney the white house press
secretary was a guest
which is a great booking you know they
get to ask haley mcinney about this
stunning report about the president's
taxes in the new york times
but they only asked one question about
the report and that question was
what do you think of the timing of this
story coming out just two days before
the debate
i i guess suggesting that there's some
sort of nefarious plot
between the new york times and enemies
of the president to
trip the president up right before his
big debate with joe biden which is
happening tomorrow night on on tuesday
night
a sort of silly question to ask the new
york times has been
reporting on his taxes for years uh
there have been plenty of negative
stories about president trump that have
come out
it's it's absurd to suggest that the new
york times somehow plotted to drop this
just two days before
uh the president's debate with joe biden
there are a lot of better questions that
uh
fox and friends could have asked of
kaylee mcinney and questions that remain
open about the president's financial
situation
exactly did he pay only 750 for two
years in taxes
supposedly not something to be denied
yeah and
but not a question fox and friends asked
unfortunately not and you know that
that's a it's an open question the
president has called the
the story fake news he hasn't specified
what in the story is fake news
uh the the 750 number uh
is chalked up to the massive losses that
he recorded
for his hotel chains um he said that
he's lost
i think some 350 million dollars from
his golf courses since the year 2000
and that's how he was able to not pay
any money uh
in in the previous decades in federal
income tax and only a small amount in
2016 and 2017.
it would be nice to know whether the
white house is denying that specific
part of the story
certainly a bombshell report and the
time says more stories are
coming from the cache of documents they
now have eight mclaughlin thank you so
much for joining us today
thanks ryan and thanks to all of you for
joining us
have a good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you